puis j'ai toujours eu horreur des
hôpitaux et puis j'aurais préféré une
chambre individuelle et c'est bien
d'avoir de la compagnie du temps car à
moins que je me suis je vais y avait je
t'appellerai ce soir d'accord omar ma
chérie tu m'embrasses pas
ben mon vieux tu te barres pas sacré
petit loup mais une paire de nibards ça
donnait envie d'aller coller sans étant
non mais dis donc
cette batterie dont vous parlez m'excuse
je pouvais pas savoir belle plante mes
félicitations aux géniteurs
bon je me présente charles frémont
demain je me fais opérer du ménisque
je sais pas ce que c'est le genou et
vous c'est pourquoi
si on me demande tu sais pas cependant
je voulais pas être indiscret